monsieur bonsoir merci à tous d'être
venus nombreuses et nombreux pots nous
regarder tous les soirs il est encore un
grand corps 590
[Applaudissements]
bonté remix et j'ai rajouté 40 et mines
ça c'est pas bon ce soir j'espère que
vous allez prendre quatre cent cinquante
mille euros il faut le reprendre le rosé
aujourd'hui
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue dans
prend droit alors pour des raisons pour
des raisons de diarrhée et si lui n'est
pas là ce soir
il sait même pas que je suis venu lui
prendre sa place d'ailleurs je mette un
peu de gel tu as compris pour faire
comme lui tu vois et donc voilà j'espère
pas bon
[Applaudissements]
leurs travaux la djamen sylvette que
j'ai volé à jamel debbouze je suis très
fier de ça donc j'ai pas dis vous voulez
vous la donner mais si qu'on me la donne
c'est pas pareil djamel si tu nous
regardes ou si quelqu'un est l'épée de
l'eau dit si tu m'appelles avant la fin
de l'émission je te récupérer ta veste
voilà à quoi ah bah faut être plusieurs
pour la récupérer
vous êtes un fan de peur quelqu'un ici
on cultive des oubliés tritsch olala
dietrich mais c'est ma passion moi vous
comme ma femme et je dis j'ai tout vu et
est ce que vous pouvez me faire une
petite danse
bien sûr on respecte l'histoire on voit
que j'adore fait du bruit pour détruire
[Applaudissements]
atik
je
oui
quoi
avant
alors allez-y faites
[Applaudissements]
m
et
à
bon
ah la la yanis comscore alors ce que
j'aimerais juste avec les distances de
sécurité
est-ce que vous pouvez venir au centre
et vous m face à bouder
[Applaudissements]
gardez vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
monsieur arrive à 42 ans ouais ça fait
huit mois il fait pipi au lit
non ouais il comprend pas y voir de si
tu parles de jos il va voir un
psychiatre il est dit écoutez monsieur
voilà le problème que j'ai depuis huit
mois je fais pipi au lit vélib
expliquez-moi vauréens vélib jo rêve que
je course dans la forêt et à chaque fois
je cours dans la forêt je croise un
lapin elle ne l'a pas me dis alors on va
faire tpiy moi je dis oui et je fais
plus il dit bah écoutez la prochaine
fois que le lapin viens vous le dites
non voulues dit n'en voudra mettre le
nom dans votre tête non non non non vous
endormez quand vous croisez le lapin
vous dites non dits d'accord il leva le
lendemain il revient chez le docteur
diallo
ça a marché écoutez docteur je dois bien
mais pourquoi parce que j'ai couru j'ai
croisé le label made you alors on fait
pipi
j'ai dit non dialoguant sert kaka
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
françois
écoutez yeah yeah mesdames et messieurs
records d'audience
[Applaudissements]
40a
à
je serai à prendre ou à laisser en 200 m
mohamed habib
alors
métro moi y'a qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous avez lu aujourd'hui dans des
abris bus à passer rina mais un odieux
je suis suivie d'un point
[Applaudissements]
excuse moi parce que comme on m'a dit
tiens faty qui flambent et s p 500 n'est
pas encore là alors on à l'antenne n'ont
pas bondi rabine vannes on est en direct
direct
bravo bouder
[Applaudissements]